hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
three months ago I made contact with
scuff the manufacturers behind the
controller's used by so many pro ps4 and
Xbox one players my task was simple I
wanted to know if their controllers
could make me a better player at
fortnight I watched countless reviews of
scuff controllers online and either
found the reviewer slating the product
without explaining the issues are worse
still the reviewer was partnered with
scuff leading me to distrust them even
though they were endorsing a product
they believed in wholeheartedly scoff
kindly sent an impact controller in
bright pink because I have an unhealthy
obsession with that color but more
importantly they have given me free rein
in my review and not attempted to
contact me during the review process so
please let me stage once and for all I
am NOT sponsored bicycie all opinions
are my own so after three months of use
the plan is to go through the great
things that scuff impact controllers
offer but also a few issues i've
encounters so with that out of the way
let's do this the first thing we need to
do is understand why scuff controllers
are used by professional gamers it comes
down to one important feature the
ability to keep both thumbs on the
sticks at all times some simple I know
but this small fact is what gives a
gamer a huge advantage on the
battlefield let's break it down on the
back of the scuf controller are these
paddles which act in the same way as
face buttons so on the ps4 that's the X
square circle and triangle buttons which
can be accessed from underneath the
controller depending on the size of your
hands your natural grip will see your
middle finger or ring finger rest
perfectly on the plastic buttons let's
take a typical shotgun fight in Battle
Royale
most of the time we all jump around like
headless chickens jumping helps in two
ways it makes us a harder target and if
we manage to get the higher ground
it makes head shots easier here's the
issue to jump with a standard controller
you'd need to take your thumb off the
right stick to press jump not only does
it slow us down eat also makes aiming
the shotgun impossible whilst jumping
unless you use the claw technique but
that is extremely uncomfortable for the
majority of gamers so by having a button
underneath the pad we can jump and aim
simultaneously giving us a huge
advantage in gunfights some would say
it's unfair and I kind of agree it's a
little ok to say the least
depending on the model of scuff we look
at there'll be two or four puddles to
use for context the infinity natively
has X and circle mapped on the rear
whereas the impact has triangle of
square to here's where things in
fortnight can be made ridiculously easy
with a scuf controller on a standard
controller building a one by one can
take a great deal of toll on your right
thumb as switching to build mode and
jumping and aiming with precision is
difficult to master
whereas on the impact all three of those
buttons are immediately accessed by
different fingers jump is controlled by
your middle finger on the left hand
build mode is controlled by the middle
finger on the right hand and aiming
remained safely under your right thumb
this change may only save a tenth of a
second each time but this time adds up
especially in build battles and the
freedom to instantly switch weapon to
jump and aim is frankly awesome when
buying a scuf it's also possible to
purchase a remapping tool just in case
you want to customize your experience
sadly that does cost a little more but
we'll get to that very soon oh another
quick note it isn't possible to map
combinations on macros to the paddles I
had hoped to map the perfect three tile
high one by one tower for clutch build
offs alas it's not possible at present
but imagine that complex movements in a
single button press yeah if we break you
down like that that probably is too far
that would be a little too close to
cheating surprisingly the greatest thing
I found on the scuff impact was not the
under pedals but instead the
hair-trigger option depending on the
game r2 or the right bumper it's almost
always the gun trigger it was even
reshaped to feel more akin to a real gun
trigger the time it takes to push down
completely can cause a missed shot or
two
the impact offers a hair-trigger option
to minimize the button depth with this
small adjustment is possible to create a
shallower button press making shots that
millisecond quicker in battle this
function improved my sniping hugely in
fortnight and I found switching back to
a standard controller I really missed
this option another great addition to
the scuff controllers are the options of
thumb sticks because scuff offer custom
modular elements to each controller from
color to length of the bumper buttons
it's easy to overlook the thumb sticks
without a doubt the thumb sticks make a
difference they can be domed like the
ps3 pads they can be concave like ps4
pads they can be made longer they can be
colored differently but it's
surprisingly it's the material which I
was most impressed with and
scientist so I can't really break it
down but the thumbsticks use a type of
rubber which clings to your thumb when
in a build battle with sweaty palms and
sweaty fingers and thumbs the rubberized
thumb sticks prevent any slipping from
my grip
there's even an option on the impact to
give the controller additional grip I
personally didn't get that option but I
can definitely see the appeal
so we've outlined the great elements
that make a scuf controller the
preferred option by most pro console
players but all that customization and
modulation is also an area to be
concerned with the scuff impact starts
off costing more than twice the amount
of a standard controller the cost
balloons further with every option you
add on I priced up the controller scuff
sent to me and it would have cost 200
pounds after-tax instead of translating
that into your currency I'll convert the
currency instead this one bloody good
pad is the same price as for standard
controllers to put that bluntly the only
way to look at this is to see a scuf
controller as an investment we can
change the way we look at scuff
controllers again by isolating each part
for example when the paddles wear away
it's possible to purchase more on the
star it's modular remember so we can
take off any part we like and replace it
with newer pieces I noticed in most
reviews that our against scuff
controllers they are usually due to a
device not working as intended I can
completely understand where this opinion
comes from as when my controller arrived
the right thumbstick kept sticking my
first reaction would have been more
furious if I had spent the money myself
but as this was a review model I saw
this as an opportunity I have to admit
it was not pleasant using tech support
but once I found a real human being
things moved much more quickly sending
the controller back though would have
seen it gone for several weeks as that
wasn't an option for me I decided to
take off the thumb sticks to
troubleshoot the problem and when I
reassembled the controller by switching
the sticks around somehow the issue was
gone it just wasn't there anymore
and it worked perfectly to some that
will sound absolutely whirring whereas
others will just see that as a good
thing I'm not sure how I feel about it
but wanting to make sure you had all the
information just in case you are
thinking about making this choice
another issue I discovered was a slight
delay or unresponsive button presses on
the back paddles once again this could
have broken me could have sent me into a
mad rage and I could have been one of
those people you see on youtubes
completely slating the product but that
said it was unbelievably easy to fix the
back paddles were dirty and needed to be
cleaned so I got out a cotton bud or a
q-tip and in a couple of swipes it was
clean again that took me ten hours to
figure out by the way before we recap
everything let's look at form factor the
current models on the market are the
impact and the Infinity in retrospect I
should have chosen the Infinity as my
hands fit better around the original ps4
controller after using a friend's
Infiniti I quickly realized that was the
better option for me in terms of comfort
saying that the additional paddles on
the impact are excellent and if you were
or are an Xbox player this updated form
factor will feel most comfortable to you
either way keep in mind how many hours
you'll need to put in to acquire the
muscle memory to use these to the
fullest anything from 60 to 600 hours so
it's an investment in money and it's an
investment in time in conclusion the
awesome hair-trigger system the
brilliant under pedals the slightly
sticky thumb sticks for grips the custom
colors the modular system are all
fantastic reasons to buy a scuff impact
controller but on the other hand the
slightly cheap plastic feel the
potential issue of one of the parts
arriving untested and of course the high
price tag our issues I think you should
be aware of and although this was a
review of the scuff impact we started
with an original question can a scuf
controller make you better at fortnight
quick building yes quick shooting yes
improved aim and jumping yes without a
doubt yes a scuf controller can make you
better at the fortnight hopefully that
will show you both sides of the argument
and put you in better stead to make a
decision on a pro controller there are
other pro controllers on the market and
if I get my hands on any of those I will
compare and contrast as many as I can
but as scuf were the only company kind
enough to send me one of their review
models I wanted to also show you the
future of their products this is the
scuff Vantage offering improved
precision and control much more
comfortable to hold I'm told offset
thumb sticks like an Xbox controller and
all the customization scuff is renowned
for I'll do my best to get my hands on
this beast and if I do I'll be back with
an objective review later in the year I
imagine from PlayStation granade it's
been an absolute pleasure I'll see you
next time
[Music]